eat a lot of beef and i mean i love beef
man i love a good steak you
no no you went vegan a while ago right
yeah i'm thinking that but i can't know
what
was eating me when i eat a lot of meat
it hurts when i [ __ ] [ __ ]
i can't [ __ ] when i eat a lot of meat i
can't [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i think
the solution to that is what don't eat
meat
you know what i can't [ __ ] [ __ ] but i
can't [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to a special
edition of hot box and i'm evan britton
and i'm mike tyson mike we got a great
guest today man nothing again
exciting very awesome this is very
interesting guest we have here it takes
a lot to get me out on a saturday
morning
to do a podcast thank you not just
podcasts but also to hotbox but i would
like i do this
you know i come in here sunday midnight
you know three in the morning tell me
when to come i'm here i love that
john heilemann everybody thank you guys
it's awesome to be here this is i've
been looking forward to this day
ever since we started talking about
doing it so here we are and i grew up
here man
not not in el segundo but uh in fact you
know my dad moved here
from uh from for the midwest and late
50s
he was from milwaukee and he when he
moved out to california the first job he
had
when he moved to la was working for
litton industries a aerospace firm in el
segundo
so uh we are we're like this like feel
like it feels like i'm in my ancestral
spiritual home but i grew up in the
valley
out in the far west valley out near in
canoga park nice man
so that's my uh that's my and i was here
for the first 18 years of my life and
then
left and um have not lived here since
but i come back a lot so la always feels
like my
my original where do you live now i live
in new york city okay yeah i love it
so you know i moved from here your your
current home
to your old home in fact i live my first
place i lived in
uh when i moved to new york in 2002 2003
was in fort greene
that's why that's where my dad lives yes
london hospital
yeah so i lived right on the park right
on on washington
i lived on at 209 washington park oh
[ __ ] my dad
lives at 208 washington park
that's crazy man that's that's amazing
yeah oh no so my wife and i live
my wife and i live there right on the
corner of washington washington park
and dekalb like right across right
across
the franklin between the cabin and
willowby yeah that's that's and you know
that park as you know man
like now it's all gentrified and so the
park is great you can go and hang out
there with the dogs and everybody all
day all night it's great
and beautiful and 15 years before 20
years before
you could not go in that remember around
1977 out they were filming a movie to i
don't know it was around 77
76 i guess the education of sonny
carlson or something
and they had all the gang fight um
pictures in washington park
a little kid we all went down there wow
man that's uh it used to not be that
that was not a uh that was not a place
you went at night no scary
not not a place to give north portland
avenue south portland
yeah it's crazy it's crazy how that that
all that whole part of brooklyn you know
the fort green
clinton hill that stopped listening if
you want like um
white or puerto rican or italian you
better not go around yeah right now
not not the case now it's like it's nice
it's actually one of the great like
as that's that there's some places in
brooklyn that obviously totally
gentrified but that neighborhood
still that whole complex over there bed
stuy clinton hill
uh brownsville those are all yeah
brownsville still
has the best yeah we can't we got to
change the name yeah right
the name is bad it just bring it it
brings up so much
stuff from the past but it's a nice mix
over there a lot of brooklyn now it's
like you got these nice neighborhoods
where it's like you know half
you know you have to worry about my
snatching your head off or something
that's that's true and that's
that's probably a good thing but you you
lived there when it was a lot tougher
holy moly listen when i go to nasa was
my life a lie
yeah was that actually true did i live
like this this is not a place that
somebody that had
nothing and weights on welfare and it's
just
unbelievable what they did there how do
you like california california is god's
country yeah how long you lived here now
i lived in before i i moved i moved back
here a year ago
but i lived here before in 1887 right
98 and you moved back out here when um
last year
last year yes right and so you're and
you're this is it you're here
you're you're done your california is
going to be your home forever now it
appears
you look you look pretty at you look at
home here i am at home but you just
never know what
um the energy has in store for you he's
got this shirt that's a that's like
that's the shirt of a person who's like
who's a cow who's this guy
that's that's an l.a shirt is what that
is right
for sure thank you you're welcome man
um i did the opposite i was born in new
york city yeah lived in park slope till
i was 10 then my mom moved my brother
and i out to l.a
went lived in burbank burbank write down
the 101 from you man yeah listen if you
lived in new york you wouldn't have this
then
energy man you'd be a girl i know i know
i might have just
turned into a weed dealer by its state
it's been it's i think it's the better
the path
i mean like i i think that both places
are great and they have great energy and
it's kind of great too
i don't know i always feel like i i've
become such a new yorker but i still
have that california thing like down
you know it's like people in new york
still there's like the
you gotta you gotta have a metabolism to
look at right you gotta have a certain
metabolic
energy high energy right but but then
the question is is there
at the bottom of that is there stress
and tension or are you
basically or are you basically chill
yeah right yeah i think coming from
california
and living in new york it's like there's
a you know you keep my metabolism is
pretty high but
there's also like this i still have like
the california that core
i still have this california bottom that
resonates with me yeah you know what i
mean yeah it's like i think you meet
people who like who can work in both
places there's people you meet in l.a
who could never
happen new york yeah and you meet people
in new york who could never hack
california they'd just be like they're
losing their minds lose their minds
right
but if you have that then there's this
kind of category of person who can play
in both places and like feels
comfortable in both places and
that's a good that's a good vibe i vibe
with that too yeah
you're um are so amazed how friendly the
people out here are
yeah why people in california so cool
you know you could talk to them you
don't know me and say hi to them
you would not say hi to somebody in new
york if you don't know them
yeah how you doing just walk right by
your ass they make it who the [ __ ] are
you
what you hitting on me [ __ ] you
know new york is weird
if you don't know them don't say they
don't have time yeah don't say anything
people don't have time i think i think
most people if you came up and said hey
they'd probably say
they'd probably say hi yeah listen when
i was you
this what happened one day i was um came
back to my old neighborhood i was 14 at
the time right
and i was living with cuffs so i had
probably a year or two so i have a whole
different life
reaction than back in black brownsville
so i'm in brownsville and some guy
on the street when i'm with my friend
and he said what's up i say what's up
man
because i'm used to being now everybody
knows me i fight and everybody says hi
to me upstate new york so i come in here
and this guy says hi to me hey say hey
how you doing and my friends and your
mic you know him
i said nah so what you say hi to him for
i said i don't know
to [ __ ] that [ __ ] don't say hi to that
[ __ ] and that's just how it was
wow you don't know no talking your
friend was still in the brooklyn mindset
yeah yeah but that's the kind of
lifestyle it was
yeah you say hi to somebody you don't
know yeah dude
i remember that guy might be trying to
hit on you or something yeah
that's the mindset i mean in l.a you
might try to say hi to somebody and they
might be totally emotionally shut down
but you know dead they're still dead in
this like dead dead at the level of soul
completely dead sold yeah but like it's
almost like a zombie soul
you know like this like the soul of one
of those zombie dragons you have game of
thrones it's true
two different coaches yeah it's totally
too totally different
but similar in certain aspects
i think there's a level of thinking
happening in both
cities yeah that you know is very high
level
new york is this way what well it's
funny like
this way well just on like just just
even like you think about on the
if you go yeah i lived i lived so i grew
up here and then
i've lived in a bunch of places i lived
in washington dc in chicago and london
and uh and boston a bunch of places and
then at one point i
went up and lived in san francisco for
about four years um like 1998 to 2002
right before i moved to new york
and what's cool is um and the thing that
you're saying i think that
is true if you think about these big
broad
social change you know whether it's like
whether it's legalizing cannabis
or gay marriage or the environmental
movement or whatever like big like big
things that have changed the
country um a lot of them start here you
know it's like
a lot of them in northern california and
to some extent in southern california
where
the social the progress takes root in
california
and california is you know 10 20 years
ahead of the rest of the country
and then the sort of next the east coast
which everybody thinks of being a super
liberal everybody thinks california's
super liberal too but
it's even though they're both liberal
politically
the the change often starts here and
then sort of gets adopted by
other progressive minds outside of
california so it's like california is
like the birthplace of a lot
i would say i would say 100 percent yeah
and that is the black power movement
right yeah
california totally you think about all
the [ __ ] in the late 60s
that came out of that northern
california scene whether it was like the
free speech movement
the black power movement the the yeah
the
the environmental movement computers you
know and all the stuff around
people taking control over their lives
through technology you know the notion
of personal
technology and the ability to like you
know use these big computer systems
where we have this where it's individual
right that's like that's a huge social
change too and a lot of that stuff took
root up there and then you know
eventually kind of like the the thing
starts on the west coast
and gets adopted then on the east coast
and then eventually washes over the rest
of the country when
you know when it gets more broadly uh
more broadly embraced
but that's why i think there's something
in common between uh california and new
york even though they're totally
different in the vibe of the place and a
lot of
the metabolism is different it's still
the openness to new ideas you know tends
to be
you see that that's the thing that holds
la and new york are kind of in common
you get those places that
are willing to embrace change in a way
and then kind of push the boundaries of
what's
what's considered conventional or
acceptable and you know
still the case the cannabis isn't legal
in new york state you know which is
you know you think everybody says new
york it's like the most liberal place in
the country
right it but it's but you know they're
still behind on some stuff like that you
know
we're going to get there it's not going
to be it's not very far off now but it's
not
it hasn't been at the forefront of that
change what do you think about
in new york city the stop and frisk
situation
they still have that now that they
stopped that yeah they stopped that you
know
they stopped that you know de blasio
moved away from that i think you know
it was uh you know you think about the
period it's very costly
yeah you know it was not it was not you
know you think about the three terms
that mike bloomberg had as mayor were
really good for the city in a lot of
ways
and there were a lot of things that were
um you know the city got better
in in almost every way that you could
that you could measure but there were a
few things that were still [ __ ] up
that needed to change and i think that
was one of them for sure
um and uh you know it's a
you know there's it takes time to change
some stuff you know
yeah i mean for sure you know that's uh
that's of course a
a giuliani thing you know from from
where it started was back before that
and you know just uh
uh it's a pretty good place now you know
it is new york's a pretty good place
it definitely is it's a mecca when i go
there
i get to visit probably once a year and
houston you grew up in park slopes yeah
born parks love
yeah well born at saint vincent's in new
york city
and you know then grew up in park slope
so you and mike basically had like
brooklyn
they have kind of like brooklyn yeah
brooklyn brooklyn brooklyn dna in common
yes that's why you guys are doing this
podcast together
that's how we came together so yeah you
guys have the seven one
down and deep in your steep in your in
your gut somewhere you got the seven one
eight
absolutely seven seven one eight five
big time good bro
it said brook it's the funniest thing
when i lived we i'd lived in brooklyn
for
from for 10 years more than 10 years and
what happened in those 10 years from
2003
to about when i left in 2016. so i was
there 13 years wow [ __ ]
um a long time um i forgot it was that
long um i made it
i might have been stoned for part of
that time it's possible um
but what happened was brooklyn became
this big brand you know you think about
when you grew up there right like
brooklyn was
like manhattan was the [ __ ] and yeah and
the outer boroughs were the outer
boroughs and
people thought brooklyn was like less
right and then brooklyn
and then brooklyn got super trendy right
so it's like that whole
the brownstone brooklyn thing that was
you know the cosby family made
that as a television show made really
famous and then williamsburg where i
lived for a long time
became like the capital of hipster
brooklyn so you would go to like
amsterdam or paris or wherever you know
copenhagen
and people talk about brooklyn now like
brooklyn is like
for a lot of people around the world
brooklyn is cooler
is cooler in their minds than manhattan
is for sure new york magazine at some
point in the middle of that they did a
thing about how
uh brooklyn being you know the new
manhattan
you know in manhattan trying to catch up
to brooklyn because like if you were
you know the the the combination of it's
you know more racially diverse and all
that kind of artisanal [ __ ] going on
that's why i pray but listen all that
stuff is great
going on i'm still apprehensive about
living there yeah really
my past my past experience make me
happiness i don't care how beautiful
that place looks right
huh you know just whoa so if i took you
back to park slope and we walked you
down the street i know what it looks
like right but you're walking on the
street with a bunch of people's
strollers you'd still be like you'd
still have
the clenched up you'd be like ready for
a fight no i'm just saying anything
could happen
yeah people because in brooklyn they
drive by in cars get out of the car they
don't do more brought no drive-by but
they get out of cars and start trouble
people new york people
yes anything people see you it's just
weird
i know brooklyn for being violent yeah
you know you're on park slope and you're
not
in um and you're not italian you're dead
[Music]
you know you're dead if you and um
howard beach
you um you're black you're dead yeah
it's hard to i think it's hard to get
over like when you have a the formative
experience of your life where you have a
certain kind of
like you grew up someplace it kind of
doesn't matter if the place changes a
lot you sold it it's still seeing them
dead bodies on the streets yeah
you know you never forget that yeah
it's uh it's it's gonna go that's a wow
remember he got shot here
i remember they threw that um big boat
off the roof on the refrigerator off the
roof on the propeller in the cops car
here
and you know wow this place is beautiful
white people live here in there holy
[ __ ]
that's how i think i said holy [ __ ]
i even saw you white man she said yes i
am i'm saying she's talking [ __ ] and
everything so i'm saying whoa
they own the neighborhood now it's just
a trip i had changed like that it must
have been [ __ ] weird for you to do
the broadway show
right hey um yeah and i was
um when i was a kid right down the
street where i would snatch people
chains and snatch their pockets out
their wallet
or people on the street was after i did
it that next day i would come by
and the people that owned the store so
you little [ __ ] start throwing
things at me and chasing me because they
saw me snatch the chain the other day
and now i walk down the street everybody
it's mr tyson mr tyson got to get you
all together mr tyson mr tyson
mr tyson and that's really freaked me
out what a trip
yeah it really freaks me out what a trip
it's like uh i mean you can't escape
your past right
no i don't try to escape no i mean just
in general people i don't mean you but i
mean just in general your past is your
past like you have
those those associations when the stuff
that like that like your
idea of what what a place is like from
when you grew up is so powerful
how much how they leaves those
impressions they're never going to go
away
like somewhere no matter what it looks
like no matter how much has changed you
still have the thing of like
this is what it was like when i was when
i was coming up right and that's what
was that movie on when the old man had a
little kid had to open and say man i
have more sir please what was the name
of that
play you remember that play he asked for
more but the guy was the kind of guy
he had all the little kids they lived in
london they had all the kids go out and
steal and bring the money back to him
um it's a charles dickens charles
dickens yeah um
we had our parents we had our parents
friends and our job was the wrong people
my parents my um
my mother would have a boyfriend i have
a man i don't know was a boyfriend i
never saw him before
have a man come at 60 man we rob and we
cut his pockets and you know rob him
then have an older guy come up and throw
him out or something like that what you
stole my woman it was just everything
was a scam everything was about beating
the system my whole life was um [ __ ]
um
consistent about beating the system or
the white man or whoever it was that
owned this world and we were [ __ ]
um subservient people but we had to come
up some kind of way
i had no idea that i was just poor and i
was uneducated i didn't know what to do
and i didn't know how i got put in this
world what was my
crime
what do you think john i think
you know i think that your story is like
one of the great american stories is
what i think i mean i
i was watching i watched on the way out
here uh
two movies that i'd seen before but i
watched them again just for the hell of
it because i thought it'd be cool to
watch them i watched the toback movie
and then the then spikes movie and just
thinking about the you know i think the
the the you got a lot of life in front
of you you and i were born like six
months apart right you were born 66 yeah
right so
june june 30. so january 23rd 66. so
we're six year
six months younger than me basically
right so you got a lot of life still
ahead of you where
i hope we're going to be around for a
while longer so who knows where the
story goes but
just this part of it you know you think
about where you came from what you live
the good and the bad right just the
whole arc of it it's just a great
you know if you think about america
in the second half of the 20th century
and
you know now into the 21st century the
the story you lived
from that description of your childhood
through you know the rise the fall the
rise the fall you've had a couple rises
a couple falls
it's a [ __ ] great story i mean like
again it's the good the bad and the ugly
but like
as a as a story of of overcoming
adversity of
reaching the highest heights you know
and and then having to suffer various
kind of
challenges and setbacks and overcoming
those and getting to where you are it's
like
it's a you know the story is the ending
has not been written like i said you got
a lot more to go but
if you were gonna write like about a
great you know you're thinking about a
like what would be
among the many great american novels
that could be written this is a great
it's just a it's a fantastic
it's a fantastic journey you're on
that's nothing that's right that's right
this is incredible it's incredible it's
an incredible [ __ ] tale it's what it
is
it's interesting that you said it
because um life is um
i don't know i explain it like this when
i say like i know somebody that
grandmother was a slave i've known
somebody who's old enough and his
grandmother was a slave
so i'm saying he knew his grandmother
and he knew me
so this man knew a slave and he knew me
wow the distance between the two it
seemed so far away but
it's not yeah it was like it was one of
the things chris rock talked about i
remember a few years ago school
a couple years ago chris rock did an
interview somewhere that i saw
where he talked about how his
grandmother
i think his grandmother but not his mom
i think but
i think it was his grandmother who in
south carolina
like within his lifetime his grandmother
used to have to go
when she would get uh when she would
have to have dental work done
she would have to go to the veterinarian
in south carolina because
like no dentist would see a black person
so if she had to get a tooth pulled or
something she'd have to go to the
veterinarian to get the dog to get her
to get her tooth pulled right oh yeah
and that was like
but that's like a thing where you're
like it's like chris rock and it's like
this is he did this thing is maybe four
or five years ago i remember reading
this interview but
just to your point about like he's like
you know my grandmother used to have to
go to the veterinarian to get out get a
tooth pulled right
that's like within my lifetime that's
how [ __ ] up things
no um yeah this is interesting
this is very this is what we do you know
the scar this has happened this is the
grandmother but it left a scar
on him yeah right totally yes you don't
even know this woman probably yeah but
he left a scar on him yeah
you know and that's how it is in all um
i don't know i know definitely black
communities we're scarred from the past
you know most of our pain the pain from
the past
you know and we um we internalize them
to the future
you know
i mean that's the other thing i think if
you've lived your life
you just got an incredible number of
stories too like just i'm a great you
know i love story i'm a storyteller
right so
you know i think about just having lived
you know the things that people are
obsessed with in america right
they're obsessed with money they're
obsessed with fame
they're obsessed with winning they're
obsessed with celebrity
they're obsessed with a lot that's a lot
of stuff that american culture is
obsessed with right
you at various times have been at the
absolute pinnacle of all those things
right the greatest winner in your in
your
thing that you competed in in your sport
you know
made a shitload of money lived at the
highest level of glamour celebrity
fame fortune media attention
tabloid culture going to prison like i
mean all the [ __ ] that we're all
obsessed with
at one time or another you've been the
at the absolute
top of the mountain or the the you know
going to prison at the absolutely
you know the depth of the bow the valley
you know and again people are obsessed
in this country with prison too right
like we
have people watch [ __ ] prison [ __ ] on
television all day long you just have
lived this like
you know for all the categories of
things people obsess about
you have had some experience with and
not just an experience with but like
the most extreme experiences with and i
just like when i hear you tell the
stories you tell
the memories you have good and bad i
just think like it's kind of crazy that
you've been
at the center of so many of the
different like
things that people in this country spend
hours and days and months like just
obsessed with that
you say that because all these things
you see all these pinnacles of success
all these uh
venus and all this stuff all i
experienced and then i experienced a
toll and none of it meant
anything i haven't seen nothing right
it's nothing it doesn't exist
yeah i haven't been anywhere i haven't
made my first step
yet so when does it happen yet when i
die
do i start living then now that's where
in my mind that what happens when i die
it's a good question that's what i can't
answer this energy that i have like the
energy you have right now
even in your mind yeah whatever it is
what happened what happened
what happened with that energy the
energy that's okay did the energy die
that this energy we have it just go
black out and
die or does it you know does it travel
somewhere into a bug a butterfly a rock
or tree
what do you think john you know about i
don't
i don't have a clue i know about the
toad and you know um i do
and it's a i think all of the
this is another category who are you
john who am i will you
what's your purpose john those are good
questions i got the toad right here
in front of me or at least a version of
the toad yeah so i think you know
it was funny i was just literally on tv
a couple days ago talking to
um uh to this guy uh
who wrote this book do you know this guy
michael pollan yeah that is yeah i'm
just finishing how to change your mind
right so pollen is you know a famous
uh famous writer lives up in northern
california
and had written most of his career about
food and
and particularly about vegetables like
wright has written
wrote this book called the omnivorous
dilemma uh
and wrote great nutritional yeah writing
so the dude's uh so the dude's like very
he and he got interested
in psychedelics because of his interest
in in plants
like as a as a nutritionally and
otherwise but he's obsessed with plants
right so
and he's written huge best-selling books
the omniverse delivers was a giant
number one new york times bestseller for
a long time
so he wrote this book that you've read
or almost through yeah and i'm sorry
about the name thing
he always takes me two it's not across
the bear it takes me two but it always
takes me two times we just met so i got
i'll never [ __ ] it up again thank you um
but he wrote so he's written this book
about uh about the psychedelic movement
now like where it is now not the 60s
version not
tune in turn on dropout not like the and
that there's like a lot of legitimacy to
that too but
he gives a little history of that which
i thought which is cool
but it's funny because his book um
is about the fact that the
to a large extent about what's going on
with um
the increasing acceptance in the medical
community
of the therapeutic benefits of various
kinds of psychoactive drugs so it's like
from
from mdma ecstasy to organics
like psilocybin and the toad and other
like organic ibagain other stuff that
people take that grow
out of the ground but all of that stuff
which was you know demonized for a
really long time
and to some extent lsd still is yeah um
but all of that stuff which was
demonized by the culture for so long
now it's starting to change and and it's
starting to change
because of a relatively small number of
people who were
who have fought this fight for years and
years a friend of mine
when i was uh at i went to harvard as a
graduate student at the kennedy school
of government
i see you and um
i say that though not to be not to brag
but just because i met a guy there in
1988 whose name was rick doblin
oh yeah of course some maps head of maps
so multi-disciplinary associations of
psychedelic studies and rick
had started maps a couple years earlier
when i met him in 88 and so i've known
that guy now
40 that's 30 years 30 over 30 years i
met rick
and rick ad in 1988 was talking about
how
mdma psilocybin marijuana to a lesser
extent but he was mostly focused on the
psychedelics
had these potentially huge therapeutic
benefits for
terminal cancer patients for uh soldiers
with ptsd
for all that stuff right and this was
1988 okay
wow in 1988 we were i thought in 1988
there was no way that that weed would
ever be legal
there was still a huge thing that you
had to decide in 1988 if you went to get
a job someplace like
am i going to allow myself to be drug
tested that was like the [ __ ] war on
drugs
i don't want to know i got took this no
drugs right but that was the but that
was the big discussion right you had
for sure nancy reagan just say no all
that [ __ ] was happening
you know was that was a big cultural
moment so to have somebody in 1988
say to me hey you know what like first
of all weeds definitely be legal in our
lifetime
i'm like i don't think that's true i
like i remember that he was sitting in
his apartment he's holding a bud this
big and i'm like
okay i like that let's smoke that i can
smoke that whole bud
and i still you're not gonna convince me
that that's gonna be legal in my
lifetime and now it's mostly there right
but he also was talking about the
psychedelic stuff and he was like this
is my cause right i'm gonna try to work
within
real legitimate government channels to
get the fda
and the dea and all of the the
appropriate authorities
to reschedule some of these drugs so
that we can start to a a do research on
them
to prove that they're medically
beneficial and then to start actually
using them with people who can who need
them right in 1988
and i was like rick i love you and i
believe in this cause
and i had done all those drugs and i
loved them all and i thought they were
great and i could see
like i'm not just from a recreational
standpoint i could see what he was
talking about i'm like i can imagine
that a cancer patient or uh
someone with ptsd these could be
powerful things that could alleviate
people's pain and help them to
uh help them to to to to heal and to
achieve higher understanding
and all that stuff but i thought the guy
was [ __ ] nuts
to think that that was ever going to be
achievable on a timeline that would be
meaningful to me and him
and michael pollan's written a
best-selling book about how
it's happening yeah like at the best
medical schools the best research
institutions in the country
are breaking through and saying yeah you
know what this shit's real this is this
is going to work it is therapeutic it is
legit
the harms are minimal if any and we need
to change the laws and the laws
inspires you and it's inspiring of
course and so the laws are changing
and we're breaking through and so you
know i think you know it's like
i've given up my my i always was hopeful
about
these this these achievements and this
progress but i was skeptical
about it because i thought the culture
would fight back but i'm now i'm like
you know what
like the progress is happening on all
these fronts so much faster than anybody
ever thought it would happen
and there's still a long way to go but
now i'm like you know i think
we're going to get there and and people
who need these medicines are going to
get them
and people who who need them for who
aren't even as extreme as cancer
patients or
or people with with ptsd people are
going to like work like the progress is
happening this is a place where there's
a lot of [ __ ] up stuff in our world
but
on this front you can see every day that
things are getting better
they're getting better so well i think
that the the state
of this country of the world the state
of consciousness that we're in
is calling these things out you know
that's why
people are being drawn to these need to
um realize there's
some things on this world that we can't
explain well have you guys i don't know
sometimes you guys have talked about
this on the podcast but what what got
what made you start to experiment in
this area
i don't know how much you guys have you
guys might talk about this all the time
yeah
oh yeah this is interesting have you
guys spent time on this on this podcast
a lot
are you talking about it a lot it might
be
so it might be repetitive for some of
the listeners but i'm interested i don't
know man yeah i want to know which how
you got there
oh listen i'm i'm an addict i'm a really
i'm a bad addict and i'm not drunk and
um
i'm sexy i'm gonna i'm addicted to
everything
okay so i'm living my life doing my
cocaine doing all my stuff and one day
i'm
i don't care and so we're doing a part
like you and this guy's a doctor
and he's talking about some kind of drug
that's going to make me see
god five m-e-o-d-m-t nissan's gonna like
being in heaven you're gonna
and i'm on cocaine and i thought really
oh is that so
and i said where is it at he said i have
right here what's the word give me truck
let me check it out let's check it he
said well we can't do it right here
why not because i didn't understand that
kind of drug that you had to situate
position yourself i didn't understand
the drugs is what you take in the street
you just take the joke
right here and let's continue talking i
thought we were going to do but it
wasn't that
so he said wait wait and so during our
conversation he's talking i said man
where's the [ __ ] are you ready and say
oh no wait
and so we go in mexico somewhere and um
and he put some golden dust it's like
gold dust
he put gold dust in anything and he lit
it in hell
and once that once it came out when it
was all cool
once it came out whoa
oh my this is the first is what i said
oh
[ __ ] i [ __ ] up these white
[ __ ] killed me
i'm dead oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] why am i trying to prove i am
dead oh [ __ ] i'm dead
and um i woke up i guess it was
10 minutes later and man i was so afraid
i didn't what
happened what was the first thing what
would you know what that was the first
thing you did the first thing when it
hit me yeah what was the but what was
the substance what was the thing you
responded to the toad it was the toad
okay live meow dmt
okay yeah i've seen um aztec
pyramids i see hieroglyphics i'm seeing
things i'm seeing chambers of the past
i'm
scs is i i can't see myself um it's not
it's just energy my body doesn't exist
and it's just
noise and oh you can't even you can't
explain my
i stopped breathing i've died and i was
telling the guy
i'm not dead am i i'm dead i am dead i'm
dead right i'm [ __ ] dead keep it you
can be real with me i can handle i'm
dead right
and um i was so scared once i woke up i
said
where's my wife where's my family i was
everybody at
and i said do they know where i'm at
they know i'm here and i was just
um i've never experienced anything like
that before i actually died and um
i didn't know what to do i just stripped
me off my ego i thought i was a tough
guy
when it strips you of your ego it's like
ego killing
ego death yeah killing drug and once
they kill you don't know it man
you feel so you don't even know what
you're afraid of you don't know what you
think somebody's gonna kill you
[ __ ] your rape your murder you don't
know what's gonna happen
yes [ __ ] you're happy it's over but
after it's over you get that um
some endorphins that feel like what the
[ __ ] happened
and i'm just so happy to be up and i'm
[ __ ] crying i'm holding people
and that's the first time i did it right
have you guys ever done a pod
while you guys were all we're all doing
dmt oh my god
that's a it doesn't last that long when
you do the dmv yeah help yourself there
john i figured the tray's there for a
reason right i mean i
looked i considered that kind of a i
haven't i haven't done the toad i've
done
dmt and psilocybin and lsd
and i think that you know anyone who
tries these things guys like rick doblin
yeah had you tried psychedelics at that
point yeah
you had yeah i mean to me the
experiences i would say that has the
time i was a by the time i got to
graduate school
which was that was that 1988 so i was
like i was in college
in 1983 1987. there were not
that many substances that you could name
that i didn't have not tried that i had
not tried by 1988.
there were some yeah there was some it
would be on the left on the list of
stuff that there is to try versus stuff
that i hadn't
tried a lot the list was over here was a
lot longer yeah
than the list over here hey i get it
dude i totally did after i did the tour
i never wanted to do cocaine another
drink
yeah i mean for me it's something about
these experiences
that is so uplifting connecting
you know it dissolves
the disconnection the isolation you know
in any way even if you are alone right
you know but you've done
now you've done mdma uh i haven't done
mdma all right you gotta
you gotta make some progress you gotta
help him i don't know
you don't have to be yeah you don't have
to be called down i just think you
should that's my vibe you should broaden
your experience
yeah it's awful so you got one luck one
life one life
a dude as far as i know i've been really
no i think we're here a lot yeah oh you
do you're you're a
reincarnation guy well i mean yeah okay
you know i think that's legit yeah i
just you know i think it's a
it's an interesting thing about like if
you believe
if you are i've always thought about the
notion of like people who believe in
reincarnation versus people who don't
right like what
how that changes your life yeah your
life philosophy if you think you're
coming back
yeah you have a different approach to
things than if you think you're only
here once right
it's not that as you mentioned ego
thinking that we're coming back saying
that
yes yeah i don't i think that
i do the only way i can conduct my life
is guided by the higher power
that i've come to have a relationship
throughout my life
right you know and that's not that's
just
whatever it is inside me yeah that tells
me
when something feels right and good and
when something
feels off and wrong you know and how do
you feel um
how do you feel everything we learned
since we've been a child about the world
has been a lie how do you feel about
that
uh i don't know what that means what
does that mean i don't know you know i'm
[ __ ] um
adam and eve [ __ ] christmas and all
that bush and how this [ __ ] got with
you know martians came here and fairy
tales did this and
my my baby my baby was born without a
dick and [ __ ] you know all that stuff
well some of those stories i'm familiar
with and some of them i'm not but um
i don't you know
some of those stories like like the
santa claus christmas thing i'm familiar
with the [ __ ] baby thing i don't
know as much about that
that's not what i know am i being born
without having i understand i'm just
i'm just saying i don't i'm i don't know
man i think you know
someone would say the ego the angels
blessed them with yeah
bless these people yeah john so what is
your take on life then
you think we're just here what kind of
[ __ ] once what kind of a podcast is
this
this is like a [ __ ] i'd like it are
you my priest my shaymin
which one more likely maybe i'm more
like a shaman than a shaman
i don't know man you're that this is not
my area of expertise but
you are your feelings about my my sense
about my this
ties into your overall feelings about
the state of the country yes
trump is a president i think it's
[ __ ] you know
abortion laws being put into place in
2019
all of this how do you feel about
somebody telling everyone what to do
with her body like she's useless that
she doesn't know what to do with her
body
she's a [ __ ] puppet i feel very
strongly opposed to that posture
and i find it really troubling that
there's anybody who thinks that they
should be able to legislate control over
over women's or anybody else's bodies uh
so i'm i'm against that
how do i who gives them the right to
have even [ __ ] authority over women i
i think why do women have a [ __ ]
authority or [ __ ] counsel for their
own [ __ ] living
because they're totally two different
species there's a question there's a
question a lot of women are asking
especially right now when they feel like
they're
having a lot of their rights constrained
or stripped away from them i'm not a
liberal guy
you're not no and i really believe that
you know women should have their
people they should be able to live their
own right and they shouldn't even have
their own laws because we're [ __ ]
we'll violate them anytime we get a
chance that's our nature as men
to violate the weakest sex even the
kindest men yeah
uh i think i don't know what's what's
our question what's the question on the
table i don't know john
[Music]
well i just uh you know as far as
here's my question here's my question
yeah go ahead why does it
matter why the [ __ ] does it matter
to stand up for what you feel is right
if this life is trivial and you only get
one shot at it why is that important
well i'm not sure that i i i we're going
out to uh
this is like a you know not a political
philosophy question but a philosophy
philosophy question
and again i i claim no expertise to this
nor do i think anybody really could
possibly give a [ __ ] whenever think
about it but i will say that i think
that
that to say that you only are here one
go round
and that there's no either reincarnation
nor heaven or
you know there's no afterlife if you
believe that you
are here as a corporeal being you're
going to be here forever many years and
when you die it's over your
consciousness is done
you've finished i don't think that's at
all that the corollary to that is that
life is trivial
or that i think you know you could argue
the opposite and that you know
we are you know we have a sort of
profound obligations to
our fellow travelers on this planet for
however long we're here and that in fact
the the the the notion of life as a
uh as a finite thing sort of increases
the level of responsibility that you
have
to uh to take that limited gift that you
have and make the most of it and that
part of making the most of it involves
responsibility to your your kids uh if
you have them
and your grandkids if they have them um
you know to your elders who bring you up
that you have a you have a
you're more you know this is if you only
got one shot at you've got to get it
right
and and and i think you know the fact
that
that we as a species i don't have
children so uh i speak as someone as an
observer of it but like
that we have that there are lots of
people out there who have you know
descendants right and that our
obligation in our finite time here is to
try to make sure we have children as
good as it could be
for them going forward that like so that
i i'm not sure that i that's like
my to the i think you can feel that
right now i think you can feel a
profound sense of social and political
responsibility
uh regardless what your view is about
these things whether you think that
they're whether you're an atheist or
whether you're a christian or whether
you're a jew whether you think there's
an afterlife whether you don't
i think all of those things still push
you towards having
uh having a sense of responsibility a
collective responsibility to try to
to make the the place that you are for
you and your descendants and the species
and its descendants
to make that place as as habitable and
sustainable and
just as possible um so that's i don't
know that's not a i don't
that's not exactly like potted world
view for me but that's
i think that's the answer i think i
think that's the answer to the question
of why you should give a [ __ ]
if we're only here for one life i don't
think we know anything
that's like that i agree with that i
think we don't know anything i was told
if you take a guy
that lives to be a hundred years old and
he parties all his life for 100 years
and you take a guy
that discovered the world for 100 years
and that's what he did for a hundred
years
at the end of the day they both wouldn't
know nothing about the world
this world isn't you know it's um it's
unknowable it's it's
inconceivable it's interesting i i know
what it looks when you look at us on a
and uh with a camera inside the
um the atmosphere you see the other
planets it's almost like we're in a body
we're in some
large body and we're [ __ ] probably a
cancer or something in this body
maybe we're just bacteria yes because
it's sorry to give you the impression i
know this is like we're like man
no john i just you're you're the back
table no we all back we have some nasty
[ __ ]
we didn't get those shots yeah if we
didn't get those shots
because right now we go to those um
jawas those guys that's in
india on the island that never seen men
for like 60 000 years see
and if we go right there if they don't
kill us with the spears we're going to
kill them in two days or two weeks
because we're [ __ ] filthy
and we and we have shots we have shots
and we're going to still kill though
yeah it's pollution so what's like
what's in the
you guys don't like when you have to do
this this podcast i looked at the
the many guests who've been on it and
they've said it's an awesome achievement
you guys have got this thing going
um there's some great conversations that
happen here but you haven't had a lot of
people in here who've like taught you
guys don't talk a lot of politics in
here right
no it's not like a thing you do so like
i'm curious like what's your you know
most people let's do it most people in
the country right now
wherever they stand on the spectrum feel
like have a very strong reaction to the
present united states like yeah
a lot of people hate him some a lot of
people love him he's got you know but
it's very polarizing
and and there's a sense for a lot of
people right now the stakes are really
high right that like somehow
this presidency is a little different
you go to your thing about like you know
how many chances you get like why
on some level you could you know you say
well you know the present change can
change every four years why do we give a
[ __ ] about any one of them you know
there have been there's been a lot
there'll be a lot more you know
anything's you know remediable down the
line and yet for a lot of people right
now they feel like trump is different
it's not like
right they don't look at trump and say
well here's a president who's kind of
he's here transiently he'll maybe do
some damage maybe he'll be good
depending on your point of view but
eventually he's gonna go
more people right now feel like it's a
[ __ ] four-alarm fire it's a state of
emergency like the country's at stake
the that that the gravity of all this
stuff the trump again whether you love
him or hate him
either poses a unique uh capacity to ch
to make america great again
or you think like most liberals and i
would say a larger number of people
just statistically it's true that there
are more people who don't like trump
than like him
you know who are like this guy's a
threat to american democracy yeah he
could [ __ ] the whole country up and we
can never recover
so that's how people feel right now out
in the world so i'm curious like
you know what do you guys think about
that do you guys think this is you're
giving people i didn't give a [ __ ]
i think american people panic too easy
they're quick to panic before they want
to um
what i mean what can i say um dissect
the problem
hell [ __ ] they're coming oh [ __ ] the
[ __ ] are coming oh god this oh god
this and um
we panicked too much without analyzing
the situation yeah
and that's what i believe and we
definitely that and i believe
trump brings out of a lot of fears of us
because a lot of people with that
mentality believe whatever he says is
true oh [ __ ] the mexicans are coming to
get us
we need the wall right you know it's not
because
you know some people look at you this
guy's a [ __ ] idiot or something and
then some guys can look at him say he's
right he knows what he's talking about
right you know but the name the deal is
is that it's about you as a human being
the majority of the people work like
this because i was one of them [ __ ]
poor slobs we um we but we have no
information
so our information is just the
television which is live and after the
television tells us what happened we go
on the neighborhood and we explain what
the television told us and this is
what's going to happen
yeah now is that just um propaganda
not only propaganda but that's just uh
such a um
antiquated way of getting information
and believing information
it's a whoa you know yeah it's the
people it's our minds that are
molded we've been molded for hundreds of
years thousands of years hundreds of
thousands of years
and then we've been changing you know we
go from slavery
we go from slavery we go to surface and
then we go to communism and then we go
try to go to a capitalism
and then um capitalism poison everything
it takes communism and now
we're going to start selling things in
communism we'll sell pictures of my own
communism that we'll still be communist
but that won't be bad
we'll live we live like um we live like
capitalists
and that's just what the world is going
through there won't be no more on
communist is only a name now
there's no actual calmness that's really
happening in the world
you know that's just what's really
happening i didn't allow it not in
cambodia not none of this is not russia
no what are you what's russia west is
the most capitalist country in the world
probably
but how is it run with the people how is
the economy
the economy is magnificent but listen
they need to uh wow
i don't want to get there yet hold on
hold on i want to answer john's question
from my perspective please
the tie i think the title of your show
the circus yeah
is a perfect explanation that i would
just explain in a circle yeah
i mean so just explaining this you know
to me it's it's
it's just a circus to me man look
there's no
yes i don't know yeah i don't have a lot
of faith in it
and i'm very skeptical of my government
well it's funny i think that there's a
there's a lot um like in that
is like a lot of like you're not alone
you know there's like millions of people
like you like that's a more common
you know i live in this world where i'll
take politics really seriously and i
think i'm but i'll
argue to the day i die that you should
because it has a huge effect on millions
and millions of people
but we you know for the people who like
follow this stuff day in and day out
they have very you know various opinions
about things right and various things
about people and assessments and what
policies they favor what personalities
they like or don't what they think is
politically effective
in the end though they all feel like
there's a caring about it that much like
knowing that much at a detailed level
and having those views
is sort of like conditioned on the
notion that you think that it's a legit
enterprise right that like that that
that these are the legitimacy of the
whole thing
of the whole game is inbuilt in that way
of looking at it but what i think is
true is that if you go around and talk
to a lot of people just in the country
they don't their their presumption isn't
that their presumption is it's all a
[ __ ] scam
yeah and that like this the system you
know these are part of the reasons why
trump was powerful
right because like him talking you know
you talk about the system you know
bernie sanders and trump are powerful in
a lot of ways in
a similar way at least you weren't 16
because they were like the system is
rigged
now trump is full of [ __ ] about most of
it but but as a thing that people heard
over and over again which was you know
the system is rigged everybody's kind of
trying to [ __ ] you over
and this whole thing in washington is so
[ __ ] dysfunctional and so corrupt and
such a [ __ ]
bunch of [ __ ] that what i'm going to
do is i want to blow the whole [ __ ]
thing up
yeah and for a lot of people in 2016 who
voted for trump it was like and for
sanders
yeah in different ways obviously totally
different guys
but the set that thing i totally agree
with that visceral thing for a lot of
people was
i know trump's a clown i know he's a
[ __ ] liar
i know he's not really a billionaire i
know all that stuff there are a lot of
voters who felt this way i know all the
things that are [ __ ] up about him
and even i i know he says this racist
[ __ ] about about mexicans across the
border
i know all that stuff but you know what
like if i vote for the other person
the same shit's gonna happen it's just
gonna be more of the same [ __ ] and the
last like 30 years has does not help me
very much
it's not really working out really well
so i'm willing to accept i mean i'm
speaking here as a lot of people who
voted for trump i think
we're part of like i know all the
problems and i know all the risks i get
that he's all those [ __ ] up things
but the only but i'm i at least he's
going to change something he's going to
blow the whole thing up
he'll blow it up and we'll see what
happens hey but imagine this guys
imagine you're a [ __ ] black person
and no matter who i vote for i'm still
going to get killed by the [ __ ] cops
and another perfect example of the of
the thing so i think for a lot of people
there's just an
element of like that there's frustration
with the whole process
and their sense that it's all not on the
level that it's like it's a scam in some
way
and that that's why people why so many
people are
are pissed and disenfranchised and dis
and alienated from the whole thing
and it's how things like donald trump
can happen is when there's a lot of
people who are looking at the whole
thing just going like
yeah this is [ __ ] yeah so let's blow
it up
so i all i'm saying is i think that is
as you think about what's gonna happen
people are not less pissed off than they
were four years ago yeah
people are not less disenfranchised
people are more pissed off now than they
were four years ago
all of the all of the stuff that was out
there frustration the anger
the distrust of the system the all the
other
[ __ ] viscerally
terrible negative things that are around
in america all of the bad [ __ ]
is not better it's just as volatile and
fired up as it was then
so this makes it very hard it's not
going to get a normal election
you know and trump makes certain that
it's not going to be normal actually
because he doesn't give a [ __ ] about any
of the rules who do what the [ __ ] he
wants
so i just predict chaos i guarantee you
that anybody who's making like
like certain predictions about what it's
going to look like as this race unfolds
yeah anybody who makes really certain
predictions out of their [ __ ] mind
hey yeah what do you know about your
family
italian greek uh that's a very good
question but it has nothing to do with
donald trump
but that's probably for the best um i'm
an adopted child so i
i literally i know everything about my
adoptive family but i know nothing about
my about my genetic heritage so
you know this is interesting you say
that i always say to certain people and
then to myself
um because i did a research on something
i found something out and it really
freaked me out yeah so um
i did a research on this guy and his
name was alexander dumas from like the
french revolution and stuff back then
yeah and he's a lot he's a black guy
right his parents from haiti and he was
in
he was in um napoleon he even before
napoleon i mean he was in other guys too
the 16th flew into six names and his
army as well so but he got napoleon's on
when napoleon got on me and so i did
research on him and stuff and his sons
and everything
and then um when i'm doing research he
was
always go to war when the french
revolution had the sword
and some i'm following his ancestry
right i'm so awesome at that right so
i'm fine
and then um i realized that um
in 48 uh 48 and 40 40 probably in the
30s
his family um they turned to change
their name from dumas
they married some jewish men to
opperheimer they become
they become um fencers he's the
swordsman in the war they become fences
they win olympics they're in the
olympics and stuff wow
yeah that's amazing incredible right
yeah
but this is what i'm saying this is only
200 years he goes from black
now he's a white jewish guy wow so i
wonder sometimes who was my first
bloodline male who was the first one
where did he come from was he black
who was he you learned more about your
family as you did you know various
things over time right you
for a long time you didn't know very
much and then and then you found like
you
for some of this yeah for some of the
stuff you've done in media you've kind
of like looked at it right
among my um half brothers did a lot of
research yeah
and so what's like what of all the stuff
that you learned about your family
uh what's like what was the stuff that
blew your mind most
education musically inclined i'm not
educated i'm not
musically inclined but that was forced
in that bloodline right
and so most of these guys are teachers
musicians and stuff like that my son
loves
music it's from genetics right so my
mother was a teacher it's just what it
was that's what they did that was
important in
their life during the reconstruction
education was pretty important
entertainment was important to them you
know i mean my brother was the first guy
to integrate
um the interrace that integrated
football in his school in north carolina
football he was a great football player
that's awesome it's great to learn all
of that
yeah seriously i mean that's like yeah
but what i still want my parents my
family like the party they always
without they like dressing up looking
nice
or you know they're very southern so
they got their money on their birthday
take the money on their their clothes
for their birthday so you see money
and celebrating somebody's birthday
that's cool
very country people very country well
mike you're not
formally educated but you're an educated
man that's probably my insecurity for
not being formally empty
and uneducated i wanted to just know
everything and everything i know i
realized it's a lie but
if you know it just knowing a lie is
knowing something
you know it's knowing these lies that
make you somebody just because they're
lies
everybody knows there's lies but if you
know them you're cool
i know nothing but a bunch of lies but
people think i'm smart how am i smart
cause i know lies
right i don't know yeah
yeah yeah it's i understand that yeah
um so where are we where are we where do
you want to go what do you want to talk
about man
anything wait i had a question before
what about the lady what's her name
again
which later this is going to be a close
election
you know trump could easily get beat and
trump could easily still win
and there's a lot of ways it could go
either way i mean i really there's no
there's it's you look at what happened
last time you look at all the stuff we
talked about before about what's gonna
happen this time
i think there's you know that you could
easily imagine a series of things
unfolding where trump was able to win
because
for a bribe for a variety of causes and
there's just so much anti-trump
important to you john who's president
because i think the person who's
president
is uh in the end exerts uh not not sole
power but an awful lot of power over a
whole bunch of stuff that affects
pretty much everybody in the country you
know like there's you know federal
policy
of one kind or another there's nobody in
the planet who's not affected
either adversely or beneficially by
yeah by a bunch of federal policies so
that's true that's true but listen
if us as us as people in america was
collectively
caring and loving for each other and
care for what you and saw people in
trouble and
went in and got involved with them and
helped them get out of trouble yes you
wouldn't care who was president because
well
we could um drive off for each other i
think there's a
i think the pride i think the government
that's not a real world i think the
government broadly defined is gonna
you know in a bit a country 350 million
people the government is going to play a
big role
in everybody's life whether it's some
people's have bigger it has bigger roles
some people have a smaller role but
there's
once you recognize that there's people
who who need
health care they need education they
need a bunch of really basic things no
matter what your vision of government is
maybe there's a world in a fantasy where
everybody just
collectively bands together and provides
everything for each other that's not
been the history of any place i've ever
heard of any place
in the on planet earth ever so i i'm all
for
people caring about each other more for
community-based stuff for volunteerism
for
when i'm made for that stuff though i
would be honest
we have not like i said the history of
the country is filled with violence
meanness greed
nastiness as well as altruism and
optimism and
and pride and progress they always
existed the fight that it is for us to
be friendly
well we we do we have done both and it
has been it's a see-saw back and forth
and they both exist in the country at
the same time there's like
there's a lot of division there's a lot
of anger there's a lot of hatred there's
a lot of racism there's a lot of
oppression
and there's also a bunch of really great
stuff that goes on for a lot of people
who have like who are
you know it's both right and so given
that it's both and given the country's
so big and so complicated the government
is gonna matter no matter what
and if the government matters so the
woman the president the president
doesn't get to control everything and he
in fact
has a lot of constraints on his power
the president has enough power
even with all the constraints on him to
be able to institute a border policy
in which migrant immigrant illegal
immigrant undocumented immigrant
children can be
turned away from their thing and were
torn away from their parents and put in
cages okay
so i think like a different president
wouldn't have done that
yeah and this president did that so
that's why like just you want to pick
one example why it matters who's
president that's why it matters who's
president because that's
going to decide some stuff that has a
pretty [ __ ] major effect on
some lives in a very direct way i mean
this is my word a lot of other reasons
listen we as americans and stuff are
always willing to give um
some kids over in africa giving malaysia
a bunch of stuff these people
and somalia we're always willing to get
but we're not taking care of our
minorities over here we're not taking
care of our poor over here
mike makes a great point not that
we don't give a [ __ ] about blacks here
why we care about blacks in africa
i i do not think i do not think we have
to in a in a world that's not i don't
know
i think we can care about both mike
right can we care about both we can care
about we can care about both right
but why don't we well why don't that's a
deep question i don't know
i don't know the answer to that question
but i think that you know why are we
gonna keep getting killed
to the end of the [ __ ] world my
great-grandkids are gonna see cops kill
black
people can i tell you my theory on that
mike don't disagree with that
mike you know just like the black
community has
its scars yeah the past that lived here
mike's brought it up a couple times
today
so white
european descent americans
because this country or
that group of people for the for the
most part has failed to acknowledge the
horrors of
many past actions yeah sure that this
country is built on
and so refusing responsibility over any
of that
gives us this psychological
i don't know prison built around
ourselves when do we when does it stop
is it gonna last for another two
thousand what a hundred
thousand a million years they're gonna
continue to go are we gonna ever learn
maybe one both sides can reconcile the
the past i don't know if that's
something that you know that yeah
you know what the answer is 350 million
like you know you get the 250 million
toes
widely distributed toes and and the
practice of licking them
they could change a lot but in terms of
the outline why are people so
so predictable why are people only
certain ways and we know they're that
way then they can't be any other way
but look i agree i'll tell you what i
what you said a second ago that i agree
with is
you know the reality is that like
there's a lot of people who
you know no doubt like look you know you
start talking about historical
disadvantage historical oppression
historical
rape and pillage and plunder the
african-american community got are way
ahead of everybody
in terms of having been [ __ ] over by
america for a long time
there's no doubt about that but your
point though there's another point which
is you know
i think it's at least part of your point
probably that part of your point is that
there's there's yeah they're definitely
a flip side
but there's also you know you can
there's there's disadvantage and
like this i understand what you're
saying but like and i understand what
you're saying about your white listen
white um if they say you're a white um
immigrant and you come in your irish guy
if you make it you can get some slaves
and then you made it into society
like i said i think there's no doubt
that that's normal
there's no there's no doubt that there's
a class that is a class that african
americans like the world
doesn't stop are more [ __ ] up wow dude
man why did they never
mike keeps asking me these existential
questions about like you know like that
i don't have the answers you have to
answer why is it never i don't have the
answer man i don't know a theory
why do humans why mike why do humans why
did why does every human that's ever
lived on planet earth have like some
kernel of hatred in his heart or her
heart like you know hatred is
it's uh it's there's as far as i know in
the history of humankind
you know there have been you know people
there's been hate you know it's what it
is
you know i don't know why that is i
don't know i mean that's a that's a
that's a different level question but
the reality is that you know the
division oppression anger violence
crime uh you know sexism racism
that stuff has characterized every
society to one degree or another pretty
much has ever been on planet earth
i don't know why it is but it's
surprising
persistence learn from our past and
[ __ ] make a different life for our
future well i think a lot of people try
a lot of people are trying a lot of
people are trying to do that and
some people lessen some people more but
like i you know i think there's a you
know
it's a it's a struggle right so it's the
constant struggle it's not going to
change anytime so what do you think
about um so
your job to your show the circus right
yeah so what is your basic um
synopsis of the circus well you know we
basically do a show that's uh
on showtime that's a a weekly real-time
documentary
about politics so you know that we've we
started out in 2016 as a campaign show
we were covering the presidential
campaign
on a weekly basis so we would go out
every week at the beginning of the week
and we'd shoot
with a bunch of crews and shoot all week
long our show's not like we don't do
like archival historical we're like in
the moment of that week so what we shoot
from monday to saturday
is what goes into the episode that you
see on sunday so it's not live
television we're obviously
we've got four or five often crews out
shooting eight hours a day
and we're sort of making as we go
through the week we start out with an
idea of what the episode's going to look
like but
as events occur we adapt to
the world so we're trying to both do
sort of like tell you what happened last
week in politics that matters
and also kind of tell you a story so
it's not just like a news digest of like
here's a list of important things it's
like
we're out trying to sort of stitch
together a little mini documentary
but one that's alive to the world of
breaking news and like what's happening
in the world so donald trump does
something on thursday that changes the
arc of our narrative
we gotta pivot and kind of reorient the
show it i don't really think anybody's
ever tried to do anything like it before
it's a really really hard show to make
and also
a real really rewarding show to work on
um
and it's different it looks different
than it internationally just locally
it's it we've all we only can focus
we're only we're focused on american
politics we're we can only we only do
that there but i think there should be
i think it'd be cool to do the circus in
a bunch of different other countries and
i would imagine
there's a trip i have all out for like
ever since the brexit thing started i
thought you know if i were
in london i'd be trying to make the
circus a pretty a british
brexit-focused circus would be a great
thing to do what do you think about that
the brexit the back thick brexit the
brexit
yeah uh i think it's a big [ __ ]
mistake
there was a a sizable number of people
you know the project of you of
integrating
the various countries of europe into a
single structure was like a decades-long
project
that has been complicated and some
countries have
embraced it more than others britain's
always been a little bit on the edge of
it they've and they feel like they're
part of europe but kind of apart from
europe
and so the forces you know when they
took it to the country and said do you
want to stay in the european union or do
you want to
exit meaning brexit right it was a big
deal and a very close vote and a lot of
people just assumed that the
that the the stay campaign staying in
europe would win
and then there was a surprise thing that
happened in the same year that donald
trump got elected
it you know there was a loud populist
nativist
argument which was basically in the
country saying
if we're part of europe europe exerts
too much control over us
we lose autonomy they're trying to
impose european values on us and we want
to be
we're britain we're britain we're
britain we got to be a low we got to be
we can go it alone right and the
economics of it are terrible for britain
and they're going to suffer enormously
and everybody who
i think what happened in the campaign
was the people who thought that staying
in europe was the right thing to do
which economically for the country's
well-being it was the right thing to do
and the project of european immigration
had largely worked for britain
but the people who thought that like
sort of got lazy about making the
argument they were like
well we're obviously going to win yeah
ben have so many billionaires that lived
there and that is true and a lot of them
are not
a lot of them not from britain a lot of
them from russia russia and other places
yeah
so i think they got you know they that
loud trumpy
yeah like isolationist argument god was
able to win
partly because the other side kind of
got lazy and complacent about making it
and now it's just been a [ __ ] mess
because as soon as the vote happened
there was like immediately people said
did we really just do that like really
like
like what the [ __ ] i mean there was
literally for about a week in britain
there was a thing of everyone going hey
what about the earth gap
wait a minute what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] did we just do did we no that
wasn't supposed to happen this was
like really [ __ ] up man so then
they've spent now the last basically two
years
like more than two years now trying to
like figure out like okay like how do we
do this in a way that won't destroy the
[ __ ] country
like you know like uh uh wait a second
okay we voted to do it
and the vote was legit but if we do it
the country's gonna
be [ __ ] so they've spent basically two
and a half years unsuccessfully trying
to figure out a way to be like
okay we're gonna honor the will of the
voters and we're gonna exit but we're
still gonna like be enough part of
europe that the economy and the
financial markets aren't gonna collapse
and they have not been able to figure
that [ __ ] out that's the bottom line
britain right now is more [ __ ] up than
america i'm like we've
lost it we've lost a prime minister who
couldn't figure out anything no one
knows
the world is moving in a direction that
we're in a speed that we just um
is inconceivable it is correct it is
totally correct
the main thing that has characterized my
career
covering politics uh for now
since 19 since 1980 sorry since 1990
basically 1990 so 29 years the main
thing
has been an increase in chaos
unpredictability black swan events
[ __ ] people nobody said would never
happen happening
um and and big like
shocks to the system that made the pool
of people who are interested in politics
bigger
like dirty and and and the polarization
thing of people being
definitively on one team or the other
like when we were all growing up
people basically looked at politics it
was like oh we have a presidential
election every four years i'm gonna pay
attention to that
really for the last two months of the
election from like labor day to election
day i'll pay attention
every four years it was sort of like the
way a lot of people thought about wall
street right where it's like
you know big huge part american economy
i only pay attention when there's a
crash or a giant boom right
and and people basically were many
people were of the mind whether you'd
say well are you a democrat or
republican they'd say
i'm a democrat but they voted for
republicans sometimes if they liked them
or their
tickets split splitting habit all the
time yeah over the last 30 years
like if you think about the clinton
election then
the the recount in 2000 the the the iraq
war
barack obama gets elected donald trump
gets elected every single one of those
things was sort of a what the [ __ ]
moment and the church of like who cares
about politics just got bigger
and it became more and more partable you
need a woman president now that's
that many people agree with that and i'm
certainly one i'm certainly one of them
absolutely i think a woman president
would be a great thing and it's too way
too long it's wait wait wait too long
for that
but that thing of more and more people
being interested in politics because
it's gotten crazy
you're gonna make that lady in england
may she can't be like kyle theresa may
that's bad [ __ ] well she did not do a
great job dealing with the brexit thing
but that thing of like getting more more
people caring because more shocking
[ __ ] has happened and has been more part
of the popular culture that's one big
thing
and then the fact of nobody now saying
i'm a democrat but i vote for republican
everybody's like i'm on team blue i'm on
team red
right and back in the old days like when
people like cared a lot about like for
like inter like there's
a time when we were first growing up
like people didn't want their kids to
get married outside their faith right
it's like you know you don't want to
marry a catholic boy
you don't want to marry a jewish girl
you got to stay within the faith or
within the race don't marry a black
person or
you can't marry a white person now it's
like you know we got interracial
marriage a lot of it
um a lot of interfaith marriage but what
you now hear
is this thing where it's like you what
the thing that people care about is
don't let your daughter marry a
republican
yeah or don't as your son marry a
democrat like that's the thing that
people now are like
oh no no no no i i don't really care who
my daughter marries but if she marries a
[ __ ] republican
hello did you see arnold schwarzenegger
get drop kick
yeah where oh show it dude holy
where [ __ ] show man that's a dirty
[ __ ] did this man
dude he got [ __ ] dropped
dropped kicks like i don't hang out in
[ __ ] africa and that's true
by drop kicks you mean like a physical
thing that happened uh
well my scariest used to do the
[ __ ] this is not like a uh
look at the bullet coming out this guy
yeah that's crazy
crazy we were watching that yesterday
coming out this guy
watching a kick video yeah oh the kick
face
is [ __ ] oh he should shoot oh they
got they got to put this guy in jail man
oh look at this man this is not cool
though
this is not cool look how she's jumping
rope she's jumping her ass off
killing her look at that girl arnold
looks great
he does looks great oh not now wait till
you see a few minutes
huh you saw that girl jump rope that's
incredible oh [ __ ]
oh look at that they got that
[ __ ] oh they got
him they got that [ __ ] look at
the [ __ ] of that
[ __ ] oh okay so that guy ran up and
kicked arnold schwarzenegger in the back
of the head oh you know
he's in south africa you know they
beating his black ass but is that what
happened yeah
oh they're beating his [ __ ]
well we appreciate you coming out mike's
a big mike you're a big youtube fan
right oh yeah you love youtube
i love it all night oh no i'm gonna
leave here and go home and watch it till
i fall asleep at like four in the
morning right
just just youtubes yeah like dozen video
after video
everything and i heard something i heard
everything
i heard some statistics recently that
you're like of all the people who've
ever been watched on youtube like in the
history of youtube that you're like like
you have a pretty high ranking it's like
number three you
on what on youtube youtube clips i don't
know about what are you talking about
your most viewed person yeah like the
you know youtube right we were just
talking about youtube clips right
so i was i believe it's the case that
because there's so many clips of you
out there in the world that among all
the people who played video clips on
youtube ever in history
like you're pretty close to the top of
the list of the most viewed clips
because all your knockout clips are like
have been circulating for years and
years and years
i'm pretty dark person you're pretty
dark who is the
most yeah i seem like a dark person to
me man i guess some yeah i got some
shady parts well i got some shade on me
dude
that i that i don't that i do not at all
uh
i would not continue but you know i'm
not i would not quibble with that
assessment
i'm sure but the toad took a lot of
stuff away the toe
showed me the light man i'm telling you
didn't care about anybody didn't give a
[ __ ] had girls had just had everything
in the world doing drugs didn't give a
[ __ ] about nobody
all this [ __ ] and i did the told and i
never saw those people again in my life
never had no more i never didn't know if
the dog was over you're trying to
try you're trying to get a stat here
yeah
you can't get a stat this is [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's the worst man
[ __ ]
this you know the internet the internet
just really [ __ ] this i don't understand
it's [ __ ] great but it's also just
it's really it's a really giant huge
[ __ ] hairball
like a hairball [ __ ] right yeah a
[ __ ] burger
[ __ ] you get on there you're trying to
eat i just want to have like you just
wanna you like i got a really simple
question i just want to answer this
question i just want to play it and it's
like and you can't get the answer you
want
simple things a simple thing like yeah
what kind of food do you eat
and i i like um
food of all kinds mike what kind of food
do you i i eat
i do man i have like a very very broad
palate so i eat a lot of food like what
do you mean like am i a vegetarian i am
not i haven't
i make i'm a carnivore yeah i enjoy uh
food of uh low brow food and high brow
food
eat a lot of beef and on meat i love
beef man i love a good steak you
no no you went vegan a while ago right
now i'm thinking now but i can't know
what
i'm i was eating me when i eat a lot of
meat it hurts when i [ __ ] [ __ ]
i can't [ __ ] when i eat a lot of meat i
can't [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i think
the solution to that is what don't eat
meat
exactly there you go i don't know i'm
i'm not michael pollan but
i know enough about nutrition you know
what i can't [ __ ] [ __ ] but i can't
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] if i can't [ __ ]
[ __ ] if i give [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's so true man that is like that words
to live
like that we're done this podcast is
over that's like
the moment hey john you know seriously
you don't get anything better
you don't get a better kicker than that
that's like that's the end that's right
it's probably the only thing for the
podcast thank you so
man much you dude that was really nice
this is like a good
this is a good show we got a good thing
going here man they love going to work
mike great episode man one of the best
man
john thank you so much where can people
find you yeah information man let people
know
if i can't [ __ ] [ __ ] but if i can't [ __ ]
so true it's [ __ ] the best uh you
know check out circus on showtime we'll
be back in the fall
i'm also on msnbc a fair amount and uh
you know
like just you know pay attention yeah at
jheil on twitter at jhile on insta
j heilman on instagram j h e i l e m a n
n you know follow me on social i do some
[ __ ] there not like
trick not like not like these guys do
monsters of social media
monsters we just want to know what
life's about we just want to put the
positivity here
perspective on life because you know
people a lot of people walk around here
all day and live in life
and then all of a sudden they say wow
it's almost over i'm gonna die so what
the [ __ ] is gonna happen
yeah yeah i like your i like this next
chapter in your life man
i like it i like it i like it it's good
i like it on a variety of levels i like
the
i like the uh i like the self-discovery
piece i like the toad piece i like the
business piece of it it's like a good
like you're heading into a into an
excellent new chapter i feel like
hey listen i never thought this would
ever happen in my life i always say on
this [ __ ] i'm gonna die
soon this is gonna be over man i'm gonna
catch aid so i'm gonna get [ __ ] shot
for this guy by [ __ ] his wife or
something crazy like that
and um everything just came to know
really guys
dude nobody's like just making fun of me
dude i laugh because
it's just so amazing to hear you be so
honest about it yes
you know and you put it so
matter-of-factly
and so beautifully that it's just it
causes
me inspiration inside no but you know
what listen i didn't know how to live
yeah like i was champ i had money had
every all these um everything at my back
and go
i didn't know how to live i didn't know
what to [ __ ] do
like i said it's one of the great
american stories i'm not kidding it's
like it's
true it's one of the great american
stories and it's that it's not over yet
which makes it like i love i love the
story
where the big question is what's going
to happen next that's like that's the
thing that propels
propels every great narrative and that's
what i want to know about mike tyson
what's going to happen next
we're going to conquer the world buddy
alexander the great baby
all day when i turn him back mike maybe
you're
so interested in alexander the great
because you're the reincarnation no i i
don't know whoa
boom we're done yeah yeah we better
go we love you guys check us out on
youtube
subscribe to our channel i'm edmond
britton that's mike tyson
this is john heilemann we're out of here
love y'all
[Music]
peace
[Music]
dude